very good afternoon everybody we're
going to talk about the mechanics of
development in the conservation of
cultural heritage much like what
Stephanie said about the multi
stakeholders and the management of
things we're going to talk about we've
been talking about how problems have
resulted in crisis and cultural heritage
I'm going to give a perspective just a
few points about how development itself
has been one of the reasons which leads
to a different type of crisis and
cultural heritage there's a compilation
of five books called the Panchatantra
compiled in the 14th century talks about
this congregation of births it talks
about this congregation of births from
all over the world who came together
from different places and they arrived
at they arrived at the at the thought
that to know oneself is hard to know
wise effort is hard to know which is
vain effort is also hard man but
accurate self critics are secure in
times of strain and we have come
together from different parts of the
world today to also talk about these
things in this context India the land
which is rich in culture like many of
our countries where we come from and
with every wave of development that is
also a backwash and in the backwash of
eroded a lot of our cultural values and
our systems what I'm going to talk about
is if we look at the basic aspects of
development let's look at the main
paradigms for development which are
essential to our life and the way they
are competing where there are competing
sectors for the allocation of resources
and it is even more true in developing
countries if you look at food if I just
tell you the mechanism of how it works
suppose I take up the aspect of the milk
revolution suppose i take the aspect of
the make
revolution and how in the mountains of
india for example we decided to bring in
hi furs to replace the local cattle
we're talking about an hour tradition of
making sculptures for rituals using
butter this art form is called shizuoka
again it is done in the monasteries now
this art is dying out because the
sculptures it is difficult to make these
sculptures anymore and if you see the
network of how this goes it is actually
the animal husbandry schemes and the
schemes from the department which are
replacing the local cattle with the high
furs there's much more milk which is
essential for the children and for
everybody but at the same time it
interestingly is initiating this chain
of events because that butter of that
livestock which was indigenous is not
there anymore you cannot have butter
which sustains at these temperatures
here so you are actually in directly
impacting change and precipitating that
small crisis in that cultural element
which is very important for them it's
important to look at the networks that
development does to be able to arrive at
where you have to pinpoint your
intervention also that's for food I'll
go on to water stepwells of India
fantastic indigenous water conservation
schemes that's the trick
multi-tiered water systems with
development even with the latest
development schemes which are insuring
or 24-hour water supply which is
essential so we are saying that this
development is essential it is also
necessary and essential to understand
these mechanisms so that we can because
the solutions are inherent in this
mechanism itself so with all those water
pipelines being laid and everything all
these Indian systems are being ignored
at not just the pedal but the actual
precipitation of drought in various
parts of the country so that itself
these are also cultural elements are
seeds are water systems the things which
are impacting that the basic Tenex
tenets of food water shelter development
schemes on this essential but it is
important that we also look at this
aspect of our cultural heritage and how
it is being impacted other than the
precipitation of disasters both natural
and man-made clothing it impacts the
minds of people the fact that people
sometimes feel disempowered to use their
own clothing families within families
also sometimes children are pushed to
wear something else because that is to
local and that's too it's something in
the mind and that all these things are
pointers at the overall the overall
aspect of conservation of cultural
heritage shelter we can move on to
education the language of education
there has been a dissociation this
association of the practitioners from
the experts because the language has not
been common in terms of crafts
traditions the big development scheme
that happen by various agencies we seem
to be following the are the the paradigm
of replication of successful projects we
have seen some examples here it is
disastrous to replicate it doesn't
happen just called it that
you know an acronym the easy syndrome it
is most of our development schemes are
also also failing because we're trying
to replicate successes in cultural
heritage conservation and these are
things that we need to look at so while
we welcome development we must be
conscious of the backwash and to see the
networks with which cultural heritage is
formed the processes and it holds the
keys to how it can be conserved thank
you very muchly engine